stay at his hotel
you're right that's right he would
charge his own secret service but to
protect him right here's your bill
but you gotta give him credit because
that's his [__] hotel the new room
costs money y'all can't be here eating
up my [__] I'm the president but I'm
still running a [__] business on the
side that's right he's a gangster
they don't still eating thousand dollar
dealers put it on the putting it on us
I'm the president y'all gotta feed me
yeah I'm getting room service I'm
reading the mini bar
I'm not paying for it put it on put it
on the country
yeah is it true that he really bear this
ex-wife on the golf course yes she's
buried on his golf course and I bet he
got a mouth right there at the top of
her head so the balls can go in